what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the eternals now here's
the funny thing about this one of the
big on running theories about the
eternals in the marvel cinematic
universe
is that they're basically robots who are
designed to serve a purpose and that now
that the earth has superheroes that
their purpose is effectively served and
there's not really a need for them
anymore
this story is going to kind of confirm
that a little bit but sort of in the way
that you don't expect but for those of
you guys who are
are really unfamiliar with this and we
kind of talked about this a little bit
the eternals had been dead for quite
some time and that the machine which is
a relatively new invention in marvel
comics had basically begun the process
of resurrecting them in the exclusion
zone now the exclusion zone is a
long-standing concept right it's how the
eternals usually always end up coming
back
but we didn't really know who was
killing the eternals but we largely
believed it was thanos because thanos
has just kind of been here popping in
and out and then there's just been kind
of like
these bodies of eternals sort of laying
in his wake and the big question
is if it really is thanos who's killing
the eternals why is it just some basic
motivation
that thanos harbors a vendetta against
the eternals he is basically an eternal
himself with a deviant gene albeit from
a different sect in the same
capacity that like people in africa are
humans but they don't share american
culture so the kind of question is why
would he be going after these guys right
what's the motivation for
hunting after him the other part of this
is that the eternals usually always
existed in isolation
although occasionally they would cross
over with other superheroes and events
like the onslaught saga maybe secret
wars or something along those lines you
never really saw them
you know really get involved in the
affairs of mortal men for cersei
herself her big question here is to kind
of get involved with tony stark to find
out what the avengers know to find out
if there's any information they have
that she can gather because one of the
biggest things to know
is that with iron man having previously
become aware of the fact that the
eternals have basically
returned now it's going to turn into
iron man if for no other reason than his
own curiosity exploring what's going on
in the world with regards to the
eternals right so the avengers may have
done their own investigation you know
iron man
mr uh mr fantastic at the fantastic four
reed richards they may have done their
own thing so the idea of cersei is to
get what information they can from them
see if she can't apply it to her own
information and then come to a stronger
conclusion the other part of this is
again the character of toby now toby is
this person that icarus who's kind of
like the main hero of the eternals had
this premonition about that he was
ultimately going to die and the goal
of icarus is to save toby right to kind
of keep toby alive of course with
everything popping off
what icarus had done is he had tasked
sprite with keeping an eye on toby
making basically making sure that toby's
protected by whatever threats happen to
be out there and that if the time comes
when a threat does emerge for example
thanos showing up and trying to attack
toby that sprite would hold off the
force of thanos as best as she possibly
could and then alert icarus who of
course would return and try to
understand what's going on here and so
what you end up getting
is this interesting scenario where a lot
of it comes down to druid now druid
is is it's kind of interesting when it
comes to the eternals the reason why i
say that is in the past
he's largely been a main enemy of the
eternals but it's one of these things
where because of the fact that different
eternals are being attacked right
eternals and polaria who are not
necessarily enemies of eternals in
olympia but the two groups don't get
along
uh because of the fact that eternals are
being attacked basically across the
board regardless of what faction they're
from
then it's kind of like okay all hands on
deck everybody band together
and druid trying to understand what's
going on but make no mistake druid's
very similar to like loki in the
eternals mythos in the sense that
yeah he's kind of working with the good
guys but he usually has his own
ambitions his own goals and drives and
he really gets emers and like subterfuge
things like that and that's why
when he is approached by like fina and
all these eternals here they're kind of
questioning whether or not he had a hand
in this
the fact that the polaria eternals are
dead that he was a servant of them and
so if he's looking to essentially
begin the process of wiping out quote
unquote all the competition whatever his
motivation happens to be
why not start there and then work his
way out into other eternals
then ultimately they kind of come to the
realization they didn't have a hand in
it right there's nothing about this that
he had any involvement in and the reason
they know that is because thanos appears
and thanos starts
crushing all of them and that's the
important thing to get here right when
it comes to thanos he
is intriguing in relation to the
eternals the eternals themselves are
already
hugely powerful right thanos is like a
mutant among his own eternal race
meaning he's more powerful than the
other eternals and so
thanos showing up here and facing off
against these guys it shows there's not
really a whole lot they can do right
they face off against him as best they
can
but thanos is just too overwhelming and
too powerful now this comes from a
combination of different things one it's
the physiology of thanos his durability
strength speed stamina all that kind of
stuff
but also the enhancements he's made to
himself technological modifications
as well as you know gifted enhancements
that were given to him by mistress death
right some measure of immortality or
kind of definitive immortality although
recently he's basically died and
you know somehow he managed to come back
here different things along those lines
the only real
savior they have here comes in the
momentary action of druid who uses his
telepathy to kind of lock thanos inside
of his own mind and you get this amazing
moment right where thanos is like really
like i've matched wits against cosmic
beings right and he has
thanos has gone toe-to-toe with like
galactus silver surfer
people whose telepathic powers are well
beyond that of druid and the eternals
and he's like you really believe that
this little trick will somehow stop me
and the response of druid is
no but it'll delay you sufficiently
enough to where other eternals can
arrive
and then we can all take you down and
he's like that's ridiculous like i have
i've held the power of the infinity
gauntlet in my hand and wiped out half
the life in the universe i promise you i
can easily overcome you
and ultimately while thanos does get his
hands on druid and in the moment goes to
kill him
all these other eternal starts showing
up and thanos does the only thing he can
do which is basically teleport away but
this essentially frees druid of any
suspicion right the thanos is going
around and killing different eternals
his next targets were these guys right
here and druid effectively saved the day
and so what you end up getting here is
thina basically saying like we have to
get icarus we have to go after the
forgotten one
we have to go after gilgamesh now the
idea referring to gilgamesh as the
forgotten one who leads the forgotten is
really intriguing here and this is
kieran gillen kind of building on
some of the concepts of the eternals
over the years and then making some
modifications of his own
right gilgamesh is one of the eternals
who's been around for an exceedingly
long time but unlike a lot of the other
eternals who kind of adopted their own
names as time went on
gilgamesh didn't necessarily do so he's
he's really adopted
multiple names over the course of his
existence the big difference here and
the reason why you kind of have them
referred to as the forgotten we'll talk
about here in a second but before we do
i want to switch back over to druid for
a second because what we end up having
is druik by himself
and then a portal opens up behind him
only for thanos to reemerge
and that's when we find out that while
thanos is not necessarily the one who's
killing eternals at the behest of druid
that again much like we would expect
from characters like loki where a lot of
these guys who
engage in subterfuge and have their own
agendas that druid is much the same way
that drug instead basically asked thanos
i mean yeah sure there's a traitor among
our ranks the big question to ask here
is why wouldn't you come to me if
anybody's best suited to betray the
eternals and to help you carry about
this mission of destroying the eternals
it would be me
i'm the best person suited for that so
let's work together and see what we can
work out now following that you switch
over to cersei meeting with tony stark
and this is kind of a funny thing
because as the two of them are
talking one of the things that she had
mentioned to fostos uh you know really
when they were kind of talking before
she before she'd come here was that tony
stark's easily manipulated and that's
true tony stark's had a thing for cersei
for a long long time
but also understanding tony stark the
way that she does she's like i mean this
guy's ego and his lust are like the two
big things that rule him right
everything else is secondary so it's
very easy to take advantage of that
right she's like i'll basically
you know like manipulate him a little
bit i will seduce him and then i'll try
to find out you know what he knows about
the other avengers or
information they have they can help us
with this goal of trying to figure out
uh you know what's going on with this
machine
or or what have you who's killing
eternals and then we'll basically call
it a day right the funny thing here is
that of course using her powers
she ends up effectively shutting down
the nervous system of tony stark and
then just kind of says like you know i
have to make a few edits here and kind
of makes a statement and saying thanos
has been killing my fellow eternals
thanos is behind the destruction of the
machine
and thanos will rule the earth when i'm
done and then suddenly
she's attacked by the forgotten one
right the forgotten one just comes out
of nowhere and immediately goes after
cersei now of course
icarus shows up just in the nick of time
you know when she says like icarus now i
need you
icarus arrives here and then basically
offers a distraction and starts facing
off against the forgotten one only for
us to find out
that what cersei had done by basically
manipulating the nervous system of tony
stark tony stark heard her say
thanos has been killing my fellow
eternals dialysis behind the destruction
of the machine yada yada
that what the forgotten one heard is i'm
the one who killing who's killing
eternals i'm the one behind the
destruction of the machine and so
ultimately this is what drew him out and
it was all really a ruse right it was
the only real way to get the forgotten
one to show up here
because a forgotten one doesn't just
show up out of nowhere more specifically
than that
the question they all that always kind
of had to be asked here is if the
eternals are there to safeguard humanity
then who watches the watchmen right who
watches the eternals and that's what the
forgotten do now the forgotten are kind
of like the police of the eternals to a
degree where they've kind of taken it
among themselves to ensure that if there
are any eternals that abuse their power
in relation to humanity
try to force them into subservience
different things like that in the same
way the deviants did in the early days
of human history
that the forgotten would kill those
eternals they would destroy them right
because they deviate from their purpose
and so the forgotten one gilgamesh kind
of overhearing cersei saying
i'm the one who's killing eternals i'm
the one who's responsible for the
destruction of the machine
means that's my target right so that's
why he went after cersei now of course
once everything kind of calms down
between the forgotten and between icarus
then it's kind of a conversation point
right then it's a talking point right
it's kind of like okay
let's kind of figure out what's
happening and what's going on here the
funny thing about this
is that because the motivations and
really the purpose of the forgotten are
to keep the eternals in check
then if their goal is to kill eternals
that basically deviate from their roles
they're the next best suspect here right
if somebody's going around killing
eternals then maybe it's the forgotten
and the forgotten one right gilgamesh
maybe he's the one that's doing it right
like it's literally i mean at this point
it's turned into a witch hunt is really
all it is right the it's a gigantic
witch hunt just going after people
arbitrarily
because they satisfy whatever motivation
uh needs to be satisfied for why the
eternals think things are happening and
so that's what's what's going on here
right going after gilgamesh the
forgotten all those guys it's kind of
like you guys kill eternals right you
guys are there are the ones who are
responsible for the for the deaths of
various versions of us
why wouldn't you be doing it now and if
you are why what's your motivation what
have we of the eternals done
to basically bring this wrath that you
have to wipe out so many of us what's
the point and the response to the
forgotten is it's not us
we're not the ones who are killing you
guys we're not the ones who are
destroying you guys that's not our goal
and our motivation like that's that's
not the case like somebody else has a
hand here
somebody else is involved here in doing
these things right so stop blaming us
the big kicker about all this is that
when they take him to
to really an aspect of the machine that
the forgotten one kind of goes through
right gilgamesh starts going through and
analyzing and saying yeah like it's been
sabotaged like any scientist of note
would have found this
just by looking at it right i mean i
even told fostos
how to how to sabotage the machine the
whole entire time this has been going on
vastos has no idea how any of this
happened fostos is like i don't know
what's going on with the machine
i don't know how it's been sabotaged but
supposedly he's been working on the
machine trying to fix it the entire time
the reality is he's been trying to
destroy it right and that's the thing
like fostos is just gaining the trust of
the eternals that's all it is right just
kind of
building on that trust aspect because
he's the most loyal he's a pacifist he
doesn't like war he doesn't like
conflict he doesn't like to to get
involved in massive affairs like this so
fostos being the one behind what is in
effect the deaths of all these eternals
takes all the other eternals by surprise
right it just it blows them away and
then of course
fostos makes contact with thanos and
says like like there's people coming to
the exclusion they'll be they'll get
here fast
you have to stop them you have to let me
continue my work now the question
becomes
why is thanos working with fostos right
like why why are these two guys teaming
up
they're enemies right thanos is
considered the sin of the eternals no
eternal would willingly work with thanos
so why in the world
are they working together here and so
ultimately what you end up finding out
is the main goal in the destruction of
the machine by fostos is to destroy the
eternals but it's not to destroy the
earth but keep in mind one of the things
that we talked about in a previous video
is that while we don't have a whole lot
of history about the nature of the
machine in fact we don't really know
anything about it what we know
is that the machine is tied to the earth
so if the machine is destroyed
the earth will be destroyed fostos
doesn't seem to know this it just seems
to be from his perspective that the
eternals themselves are tied to the
machine that by
destroying the machine that destroys the
eternal's ability to resurrect and then
from there
it's just using thanos to destroy what
remains of the eternals and there's no
way for the eternals to come back so why
wipe out the entire eternal race switch
over to one month earlier when thanos is
basically brought back
by fostos and what he basically says is
like you work for me now right like i
have found a way to bring you back but
this body
is not a permanent body this is a
temporary body but understand
if you basically fulfill these tasks as
i'm assigning them to you then i will
bring you back right i will i will
resurrect you
properly and you'll actually be back in
your full form with your full power if
you deviate against me if you violate
any of the policies that i'm giving you
if you work against me
then i will destroy you i will make sure
that the body that you inhabit dies
and you'll never ever come back again
and that's why thanos is working for
fostos because thanos of course
seeks to return to life it was always
one of the contradictory aspects of
thanos for a person who is so incredibly
in love with mistress death
and is a complete and total nihilist who
believes that life is meaningless and
death is the only real
valuable commodity that exists out there
why is he always hankering to come back
to life
why is he always hankering to return it
was one of those things that didn't
really make a whole lot of sense you
would think
that a guy who's obsessed with mistress
death would just off himself
right and just be like i'm gonna kill
myself so i can stay with mr steph
a lot of that seems to be predicated on
the events of infinity gauntlet which
solidified this idea that thanos would
go as far as to wipe out half the life
in the universe to gain the affection of
mistress death that in the fact that
he's so popular nobody wants to see him
dead they want to see him alive they
want to see stories with him so you kind
of end up having to do that because how
interesting could a story about thanos
be
if he's just standing around with
mistress death in the afterlife not
doing anything
while this whole great big huge fight is
going on between
thanos and the eternals they're doing
everything they can to face off against
them and they're doing it quite well
right that's one of the funny things is
that as powerful as thanos is
one-on-one with most any eternal he's
gonna overcome them
but given the wide and varying powers
that the eternals have when they work in
unison and they come together albeit
without the unimine that thanos
is it's a difficult task for him to
overcome all of them especially somebody
like cersei who has the power of trans
modification right matter manipulation
it's one of these things where it's not
easy to overcome that especially when
she can use it to modify the body of
thanos and to cause all kinds of
problems with him now thanos's healing
factor his durability his strength and
just his general
wherewithal right his drive to succeed
is oftentimes what allows him to
overcome the eternals right that he's
just
so single-minded to a task it's wildly
difficult to overcome that
the problem and the one thing that
fostos didn't account for is that as he
begins the process of destroying the
machine
that the machine doesn't hold as well as
he thought he would and basically the
beginning of the end of the world
starts and so what ends up happening is
that as everything starts falling
apart then suddenly the machine does it
kind of serves its purpose where it
basically teleports everybody all over
the world that the machine itself is
going awry it's not supposed to function
that way the machine's broken right it's
like if your computer gets a virus i
guess and just starts spitting pop-ups
right it's not functioning the way that
it's supposed to doesn't work as
intended and so the results of this is
that icarus gets to the machine as fast
as he possibly can
and then suddenly where you end up
having fossos who tries to offer some
insight
to uh to icarus on how to fix things
then ultimately you have druid who pops
up and then modifies the mind of fostos
and so basically this is designed to
ensure that whatever fausto says
will not be taken seriously there's a
secret that he holds that he intends to
spill to the rest of the eternals and
that that druid doesn't want anybody to
actually know what's going on
or seemingly that's the case now of
course the actions of icarus of course
work and basically keeping the machine
contained right keeping the machine
controlled and then in turn
ensuring that everything kind of goes
back to normal and the world doesn't end
right which is pretty straightforward
then attention turns to fostos right
what's going on here
now that's where things are intriguing
because the the ultimate goal here of
druid is that at the end of the day
was to keep thanos alive right that's
what kind of goes on here i mean sure it
was the secret that fostos harbors but
keeping thanos alive was another part of
this
and that's why with thanos being here
and them realizing that he was the one
who brought thanos back
it's like no no to destroy thanos all i
have to do is just activate the thing
inside his body but before he can finish
this he realizes
he can't remember how to stop thanos he
can't remember how to kill thanos and so
in effect
druid has solidified thanos's full
return to the marvel universe or at
least that seems to be the case anyway
most likely in a more stripped down
version in terms of power than what
we're used to
to kind of bring him further in line
with the marvel cinematic universe but
we don't definitively know that right we
don't definitively know if that's the
case because even thanos's current form
is left kind of ambiguous in the sense
that last we saw him he had kind of been
defeated by cersei and was just like in
this sort of bubbly weird-looking form
and that was basically it it seemed as
though his physical form had been
destroyed but again we don't
definitively know of course we'll find
out here in the next story arc the big
secret that fossos is hiding though is
the nature of the eternals the cost of
their immortality this is a
really really cool aspect of the
eternals mythos that with thanos having
been defeated
what fosdos basically reveals here is
that as far as the eternals are
concerned that whenever they die
the machine resurrects them right they
go to they they're kind of reborn in the
exclusion zone they're given a given uh
i guess a duplicate of their previous
body and they're resurrected in that
body but there is a cost to immortality
the cost of this
is that where icarus had sacrificed his
life to preserve the machine
the machine does resurrect him and toby
dies the person he was supposed to save
ends up perishing that's the cost of
resurrection every time an eternal comes
back to life
a human dies every single time without
fail it's just the cost of eternal
immortality and so in effect they are
designed to save humanity while at the
same time
consuming humanity each time they're
resurrected why the machine works this
way
we don't know that's again that's the
nature of the machine we don't really
know definitively who designed it this
way
presumably the celestials did but it
seems kind of weird the celestials would
task the eternals with safeguarding
humanity
and then at the same time cost humanity
every time the eternals are resurrected
right it's kind of a weird thing there
but at the end of the day
zeros of course is brought back and of
course that leads to the death of a
human the eternals also come to grips
with that in saying at least as far as
they're concerned
and the kind of statement they give to
xeros is yes we accept that right like
we accept the fact that this is just the
role we play this is the nature of
things but that's the big struggle when
it comes to cersei when it comes to
icarus
when it comes to fina in these guys is
well we'll bring the unimine together
and we'll convince the eternals the rest
of the eternals to understand
this is the price of immortality but the
response is kind of given here by cersei
is they don't care
nobody else is going to care at the end
of the day the response they the the
whole belief they have
xeros and everybody else is that
humanity is beneath them and so while
they wouldn't necessarily let humanity
succumb to this to their destruction at
the hands of the deviants lest the
eternals face the wrath of the
celestials that they're not going to go
out of their way to protect humanity
from like themselves or anything like
that so it's kind of
sitting on this this sort of borderline
between letting humanity destroy
themselves allowing humanity to be
sacrificed
and seeing themselves as being more
important than humanity
and so the way you know this kind of
being perceived as the way the eternals
is really more of a ruse by icarus and
all these guys and what they end up
doing
is actually going to the capital city of
lumeria the home of the deviants they're
really their greatest enemy and in turn
they say like we come in peace to the
changing people we have
no desire to wage a war with you guys
instead we want to join you
help us be the changing people too in
essence icarus and this core group of
eternals
are turning against the other eternals
and the intention here is to join the
deviants presumably to bring the
downfall of all the eternals in essence
they seem to have bought in and
understood the the goal and the
motivations of what fossos was doing and
they've essentially come to this
realization
that the the price that that's paid for
immortality is simply just too high
they're not willing to sacrifice
innocent human lives to preserve their
own lives but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an
end i love this eternals run by kieran
gillen it's fantastic
it's really a more of a cerebral story
right it's really more of a thinking
story as opposed to like a single
action-packed story but i love the way
it's done let me know what you guys
think down in the comments
and i will catch you all later peace